I think this is a very great initiative
because of course the the the Nobel
Prize that everything that this related
tool is one of the great attractions
that Sweden has for people from all over
the world they want to know because it's
very very interesting
III think nobody has explained why the
Nobel Prize has this extraordinary
repercussion all over the world all over
the world it's is unique because there
are many awards and international prizes
which but no one has reached this
extraordinary respect and curiosity and
an interest that it the Nobel Prize
produces all over all over the world so
a museum in which through very concrete
examples the the importance of the Nobel
Prize can be shown you know to visitors
I think would be extremely rewarding for
for people who are so curious about the
the Nobel Prize and can follow the
reasons why the Nobel Prizes have been
considered you know two different people
from different disciplines and it will
be very very very interesting and I'll
come to see it I hope it finished before
I when I am still there you know